Kanye visits the White House the press
lose their minds and we check the
mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
so Elon Musk's theory is that we are all
living inside a computer simulation this
all isn't real yesterday he had some
pretty good evidence for his theory
because Kanye West and Donald Trump were
in the Oval Office and Donald Trump is
president and Kanye West was visiting
and that was a thing that happened in
real life and we'll talk about all of
those things first I have a couple of
reminders for you first of all tune in
today 2 p.m. Eastern 11:00 a.m. Pacific
for another special live stream of
another Kingdom season 2 episodes 1 & 2
episode 1 will be free in its entirety
only the first 15 minutes of the second
episode will be available to watch on
Facebook and YouTube to be able to watch
all of episode 2 and every other episode
in the new season of another Kingdom you
have to become a daily wire subscriber
all you have to do is click on the link
in the description also reminder Sunday
is the final episode of the Ben Shapiro
election special on fox news when
blowing out the ratings and we hope that
you will see our final episode it's
going to be awesome we have lots of
great materials so go check that out
it's 8 p.m. Eastern on Fox News on
Sunday lots of good stuff gonna be on
that show so go check that out and also
before we get to the news I first need
to remind you that you need to eat
fill your belly and do it in style with
blue apron ok blue apron allows you to
cook pre-prepared pre-portioned
ingredients into a gourmet meal you do
it in your own kitchen here's how it
works you choose chef's designed recipes
and then they deliver fresh seasonally
inspired ingredients you can cook
incredible meals in as little as 20
minutes cooking particularly have kids
it's a lot of fun and the dinner is
gourmet style it's really good stuff
blue apron says all of them in the meal
prep for you again dinner it in as
little as 20 minutes every week at least
three recipes are built with your busy
schedule in mind wear blue apron has
done the meal prep they've prepared the
sauces the spices the ingredients and
they offer a range of recipes bursting
with flavor whether you are looking for
quick and easy meals or a full keulen
airy cooking experience blue apron lets
you choose from a range of recipe
options blue aprons awesome people
around the office have been using it for
a long time blue apron comms flash up
irrigator first three meals for free
again that's blue apron comm slash
appear to get those first three meals
for free you're gonna be cooking stuff
like stir fried sweet chili chicken or I
mean this is like gourmet stuff tomato
and basil pesto pesto pizza with roasted
cauliflower on the side I mean this is
this is solid stuff and you're beat
you're gonna be cooking it yourself and
it's less expensive than going to a
restaurant
and also it's better so go check it out
right now blue apron calm slash up hero
again blue apron calm slash up here to
get your first three meals for free okay
so yesterday was the thing that happened
in real life
kanye west as I've always said live by
the Kanye die by the Kanye but yesterday
the President of the United States lived
by the Kanye because Kanye West came to
the White House
now as I've said for many months at this
point do I think that Kanye West is the
world's best political commentator do I
think that he's on par with you know the
late Charles Krauthammer no I don't so I
think that he knows a lot about politics
I don't think that he's read tons of
books but do I think that he has a
unique perspective on the world that I
do and so I think that he has every
right to express that perspective just
as anyone else would absolutely and do I
appreciate more than anything that Kanye
West has basically said look I am an
individual I'm not just a black man who
fits in your category I'm an individual
with my own thoughts and experiences and
feelings and that allows me to think
outside the box with regard to my
politics without you trying to Club me
into place like a baby seal that I
appreciate that I appreciate and when
Kanye wears around the Maggie hat and he
says that this basically is me just
saying to the world I can think for
myself that's a message that I like and
appreciate and think is actually deeply
important because even if it's coming
from a guy who I don't think is world's
most knowledgeable about politics that's
not a message that requires you to be
all that knowledgeable about politics
saying I like to get more information I
like to think for myself and I'm not
going to be the person you think I ought
to be simply based on the color of my
skin deeply deeply important message
from Kanye West so Kanye has been what's
funny is all the people on the Left were
very upset at Kanye like oh well what's
Kanye actually doing except chilling for
Trump Kim Kardashian got a woman freed
from prison okay what have you done
lately yeah I didn't even agree with
Trump's decision on that on Alice Marie
Johnson who was leading a drug ring it
turns out but she was pardoned by
President Trump because Kanye West and
Kim Kardashian lobbied it is that simple
and Kanye West has been pushing hard for
criminal justice reform so as Kim
Kardashian and president Trump is about
to overrule Jeff Sessions on criminal
justice reform in the same way largely
because of Kanye's lobbying so Kanye by
extending a hand actually received a
hand in return which is why you saw that
meme from predator going there
a of the of the Arnold Schwarzenegger
arm and the Apollo Creed arm you know
the Carl Weathers arm locked in the in
the muscle II embrace that's what you
saw yesterday at the White House so it
was wild I mean let's not pretend that
this was a meeting of brilliant minds on
serious issues
it was Kanye West and Donald Trump in
the Oval Office and it seemed directly
out of idiocracy but was it important
for the culture that there be somebody
in a prominent position to say yeah I'm
allowed to think for myself yeah that's
that's important stuff so anyway Kanye
goes to the White House and again I
don't like celebrity politics but this
is the world we have chosen this is
where we live i I hate celebrity
politics when it was Obama
I used to mock the crap out of him for
this sort of stuff I hated it when it
was Hillary Clinton used to mock her
incessantly for this sort of stuff I
don't like it from Republicans either
but and so when I say I don't like
celebrities in the Oval Office and I
don't like the meeting with the
president and I don't like all of the
pomp and circumstance and show and all
that believe me I don't but since this
is the world we have chosen and the
world we have chosen to live in it is
hypocritical for folks on the Left to
suggest great when Obama does it
terrible when Trump does anyway Kanye
shows up at the White House and things
got wild things got really wild because
it turns out that Kanye is a wild dude
so here he is in the Oval Office wearing
his Magga hat and the press are just
eating this stuff up the press the very
serious press who say no we must treat
the president with the presidency in the
Oval Office with all sorts of respect
there they're eating this up they love
it they couldn't love anything more so
here was Kanye yesterday saying that
Trump did not expect a crazy mofo like
Kanye fair enough
here he is Trump is on his hero's
journey right now and he might have
expected to have a crazy mother like
Kanye West run up and support but best
believe we are going to make America
great okay so the the press went nuts
over this particular comment for a
couple of reasons one saying that Trump
was on a hero's journey which is pretty
joseph campbell and second him dropping
mofo on TV in the Oval Office so Jim
Acosta tweeted this out Jim Acosta
tweeted out Kanye just said mother-effer
in the Oval Office / White House pool
and people like ovule cage him is he
gonna be okay Jim
and because that's ridiculous like not
to put too fine a point on it but Bill
Clinton got in the Oval Office
so I'm really not gonna go if we're
gonna talk about things that disgrace
the Oval Office like cigars have had
human bodily fluids on them that didn't
come from the oral cavity in the Oval
Office like they had to steam clean all
the carpets after Bill Clinton left it
and and there's there's a book fully
describing Rahm Emanuel dropping the MF
bomb repeatedly in the Oval Office so no
Jim Acosta I love Jim Acosta getting all
hot and bothered about all of this i
clutching his pearls it's just it's
amazing it's just amazing so Jim Acosta
anyway so Kanye says all of that and
then Kanye goes on and he says you know
what I love my Maggie hat now we know he
loves his Maggie hat because he said
this before he was on SNL and he said my
Maggie hat is just the best thing ever
which I got to admit it's pretty
fantastic the Kanye wears a Maggie hat
it is because just the the juxtaposition
of Kanye who is I have been told by the
Utes one of the cooler people in America
wearing the Maggie hat and let's be
straight about Magga hats just as a
general rule just aesthetically there's
something that my family wore at like
the Shapiro family picnics in 1996 that
you got from like the mass production
store that had like you remember they
had like a little woven band that goes
just above the brim of the cap so Kanye
wearing that as sort of a an ironic feel
is just spectacular
so here's Kanye talking about why Maggie
hats are awesome and you got to
appreciate it man you just you can do
one of two things you can either cry at
the tragedy that this is what our
national politics has become or you can
laugh at the fact that Donald Trump is
now swiveling every pop culture meme the
left ever created back on them and
slapping them in the face with it which
is just hilarious and maybe feel like
Superman you made a Superman house
that's my favorite superhero and you
make a Superman cape for me also as a
guy that looks up to you
the wrap-around list up to American
industry guys non-political no bull put
the beep on it however you want to do it
five seconds to delay and just goes in
and gets it done yes okay so first of
all learning a couple of things net clip
one Superman is Kanye's favorite
superhero which is good I mean that's a
good pick
I'd go at Batman myself but Kanye's got
his own taste man and then we also
learned that de magie hat is like a
Superman cape which is just spectacular
you could see the media members in the
room collapsing in on themselves like
dying stars it's just great and then
Kanye does the worst thing in the world
he gets up and he says about President
Trump I love this guy
now what's hilarious about this is that
until Donald Trump ran for president
this was the view of Hollywood Donald
Trump was very popular with all of these
people in the media he was very popular
he was very popular in Hollywood like
he'd go around and however people would
be back slapping him giving him hugs he
was doing cameos on every show so it's
kind of funny now that oh my god Kanye
gave him a hug everybody loved Donald
Trump until the guy ran for president in
2016 at which point everybody hated
Donald Trump but here was Kanye breaking
the ultimate taboo and making physical
contact in the flesh with Donald J Trump
there it is there's the curl weathers
Arnold Schwarzenegger hand grip just
amazing stuff and then Kanye actually
had some pretty good political comments
so we'll do the good and then we'll get
to you know the weird so he so he had
some good political comments about
racism what he said is basically you
can't use racism as an excuse for
failing in America anymore instead maybe
we ought to think about how we actually
better the country seems pretty fair to
me and this is coming from a guy who as
I understand it grew up with a single
mom in an impoverished area and then
made himself a billionaire so even
though I don't like rap and I'm not a
fan of Kanye's music his story is a
pretty American story it's a pretty
amazing American story
here's Konya talking about racism a lot
of times it's just the overall lack of
reparations that we any given point we
say oh this is races this is race if
this is race this is racist the liberal
would try to control a black person
the concept of racism because they know
that we are very proud of emotional
people so when I said I like Trump to
like someone that's liberal they'll say
oh but these races you think races okay
control me don't stop me that's an
invisible wall yes yep slow clap for
Kanye and this is the point right the
point that he's actually making here
does not require you to be all that
learned in politics and when he says
that racism is very often used by
political actors in order to achieve a
particular result in order to manipulate
people that is certainly true that is
certainly true so well done Kanye there
and then Kanye made everyone's head
explode when he defended the Second
Amendment which is just badass here's
Kanye doing that debate about the Second
Amendment going on the problem is
illegal guns illegal guns is the problem
not not legal guns we have the right to
bear arms oh no all of there has just
exploded Kanye actually saying the truth
constitutionally about the Second
Amendment now listen as I say before
anytime you get in bed with celebrity
you should expect that somebody's gonna
get screwed and the fact is that
something could happen with Kanye as a
personality that could be damaging to
all of the points that he's making here
but take it at face value for what it is
today
he is saying some things that need to be
said and when you hear an argument you
really instead of first considering the
source you may first want to consider
the validity of the argument the
argument that Kanye is making there is
exactly right now as I say live by the
Kanye die by the Kanye now I'll explain
in a second how they die by the Kanye
half of this work and then we'll get to
the media coverage which is the real
story the media coverage of this meeting
is a much bigger story than Kanye
actually visiting the White House he's
been to the White House before I believe
I mean he went there when Obama was
president actually so it's not a giant
shock but we'll talk in a second about
the media coverage first let's talk
about how you make your business more
efficient one way that you can make your
business more efficient is by putting it
on legally solid footing you know the
same time is money it is true especially
when you run your own business but legal
takes a lot of time and it takes a lot
of money which is why you need to turn
to Legal Zoom over the last 17 years
more than a million Americans have used
Legal Zoom to help launch their
businesses but that is only the
beginning
Legal Zoom also now has a network of
independent attorneys and tax
professionals they can provide you
the advice you need to get through the
daily grind of running your business and
the best part is you don't have to worry
about driving to anyone's office or
being billed by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't actually a law
firm you can count on Legal Zoom to
provide the business resources you need
and service that fits in your schedule
listen I've been using Legal Zoom since
long before they had this attorney
services now they have this network of
independent attorneys that broadens the
scope of the services they can provide
it is just great because you can I
promise you can spend a fortune on legal
if you can avoid that by going to Legal
Zoom you should totally do it
go to Legal Zoom calm right now and use
promo code been at checkout for special
savings again that's promo code been at
legalzoom.com Legal Zoom where life
meets legal go check it out
legalzoom.com okay so as I say there's
good Kanye and then there's bad Kanye so
it's great when people make good
arguments it's not as good when they
juxtapose them with crazy talk
so I do have to point out that Kanye did
engage in some very Kanye behavior Kanye
took out his phone and he proceeded to
punch in his code which as it turns out
is zero zero zero zero and then it was
funny people were getting uptight about
this because how can you reveal Kanye's
code on his phone do you have Kanye's
phone you know do you so does it matter
unless he loses his phone is that going
to matter at all but I will say that
Kanye needs better code protection on
his phone that's it mr. West I would
appreciate it if you used some other
number other than zero zero zero in any
case he types in zero zero zero zero and
then he proceeds to show the President
of the United States a picture of a
hydrogen powered airplane and this is a
thing that happened because I don't know
I don't know man we all hit our head on
the toilet and now we invented the flux
capacitor or something so here is Kanye
showing showing President Trump a
hydrogen powered airplane this right
here is the I plain one there's a
hydrogen power airplane and this is what
our president should be flying in look
at this year
you know like that well we're gonna have
Apple American company work on this
plain wood this is our president he has
to be the freshest the playas the flyest
Plains the best factory okay so it all
comes as a package man
there is no separating this out the same
guy who's saying some good stuff about
politics is also talking about
hydrogen-powered I planes so that is the
thing I will say just as as an observer
it was really funny to watch a president
Trump during this meeting because
President Trump is rarely blown out of a
room by somebody else is sort of
wackiness and charisma usually it's
Trump blowing somebody else out of the
room with that sort of stuff him sitting
across from Kanye and looking at the
look on president Trump's face it's kind
of like the look that Jeb Bush has on
his face when he's in a room with
President Trump cuz they Trump suddenly
realized what it was like to be Jeb Bush
and watch this guy who's a much bigger
celebrity just jabbering at him and not
knowing quite what to do it was really
funny so you have to appreciate the
humor in all this and also is it a big
deal that Kanye visited the White House
it would have been if we were if we were
a serious country but we're not a
serious country we're not okay Barack
Obama was fine with having celebrities
at the White House I will show you in
just one second so the media came out
how dare this happen how dare it know
it's so bad it's so terrible so over on
MSNBC the hosts over there Stephanie
ruhle and Ali Velshi they just melted
down they suggested that Kanye West was
an insane person but they also suggested
Stephanie ruhle goes this is an assault
on the White House really again in that
room Bill Clinton Monica Lewinsky knee
pads in the room a her Stephanie ruhle
saying it's an assault on the White
House that Kanye West's presence has
defiled the Oval Office here she has Wow
okay I'm doing this for everybody who's
watching us who turned their volume down
you can put it back up again that but if
you think you're going to get a soft
will play by play and political analysis
you're not because that was an assault
on our White House we're not we're not
we can analyze some of that stuff that
was said as we warned you at the top
there was a lit of profanity we there
was actually more than you heard we were
able to bleep some of it out but there
was some of it didn't make it in there
okay mom okay I love this school of
arming there oh yeah it was just so
terrible it's just so awful I mean I
can't believe anything like that has
ever happened at the White House
flashback just a few years Snoop Dogg
went to the White House you know the
great intellectual Snoop Dogg he was the
or snoop lion or whatever he calls
himself these days whatever a variety of
animal from Animal Kingdom he calls
himself to follow Snoop okay so Snoop
Dogg was at the White House and you know
what he did at the White House here's
Snoop Dogg talking about how he talked
at the White House how he smoked up at
the White House like smoked pot at the Y
at don't worry kanye west's mere
presence at the White House defiled it
but Snoop Dogg went there when Obama was
president and smoked pot at the White
House and everyone in the media thought
this was hilarious and did you and when
you got high before the White House did
you also then smoke it up a little bit
in the bathroom when you read I was
trying to get to UM saying ikg yes yes
don't you and nobody and no and I met
the butler you met the butler did you
get him some songs yes and it was
hilarious and funny and awesome
oh my god it's a great Sun Bauman's
president and then as soon as Obama's
not president no is this Stern office
mr. not this is an office where only
great things have happened this office
you know great presidents Teddy
Roosevelt FDR they sat in this office
mono Lewinsky melts in this office I
keep coming back to that because again
if you're talking about to filing the
Oval Office there's a level beyond
having Kanye West there okay so the
media again ignoring the fact that
Barack Obama was ever-present I love
this oh my god how could Trump hobnob
with celebrities
how could he have Kid Rock to the White
House here is a picture of jay-z and
Beyonce in the Situation Room okay with
jay-z who wears a what is the 5%
medallion which is like a quasi black
power medallion at basketball games
their pictures been doing that it's
really kind of crazy stuff there he is
sitting in the Situation Room in the
White House Situation Room a company by
the
on say and this was just all fun and
games it was just fun and games because
come on man
jay-z and Beyonce they're great can't go
after queen bee come on this is all fun
when it was Obama then it was then it
was Kanye going to the White House and
it was just terrible and then you
remember this remember common going to
the White House no do you remember
common is a rapper who has in the past
cut songs in favor of Assata Shakur an
actual terrorist an actual terrorist
well there he was in the White House but
don't worry it's it didn't defile the
White House in any way to have these
folks who you know common who's rapped
about supporting terrorism in the White
House but Kanye was there and Kanye said
nice things in orem Agra hat that was
what was really bad here is common
during the Obama administration it's an
honor to be here in the White House
library the tiny desk concert series has
tried to give voice to people who have
something to say in our culture who move
our culture forward and do amazing stuff
and in that spirit NPR Music presents
Commons thank you oh yeah then again
this was a White House Obama's White
House you want to talk about this is the
dirty little secret about Obama Obama
was just much more celebrity-driven than
Donald Trump everybody says oh he's a
celebrity president Trump Obama was the
first celebrity president he had no
credentials when he became president he
turned the White House into basically a
revolving door of celebrities he used to
kick remember during Benghazi he did a
fundraiser in Las Vegas with jay-z and
Beyonce so if you want to talk about
celebrity in the White House you got to
start with Barack Obama he was the guy
who really turned the White House he the
guy did interviews with glozell glozell
like the lady who bathed in a bathtub
full of Froot Loops come on come on okay
so in just one second when you get into
the media reaction to all of this which
does show you how racist and terrible
the media are it really is the reaction
this is astonishing astonishing but
first let's talk about your need for
energy we live in a fast-paced
multitasking world all the time and
maybe drinking coffee and energy drinks
isn't doing the trick well they need to
try Omax cognitive boost it's a
game-changing solution of fuels peak
performance by boosting memory focus
energy all around crystal-clear thinking
you will feel the difference immediately
folks in the office of tried Oh Max and
I have noticed their productivity has
gone up because they were totally
unproductive before and now they are
halfway productive and that is because
of Oh max
mash is offering my listeners 70% off a
one-month supply of cognitive boost plus
free shipping and that 60-day money-back
guarantee all you have to do is go to
Omax boost calm slash up hero today and
take advantage of the savings that is Om
axb oo st.com slash Shapiro for 70% off
a one-month supply this is for a lot of
folks a game-changer and it can benefit
you perhaps go check it out right now at
Oh max boost calm slash Shapiro and you
get 70% off of one month's supply plus
free shipping and a 60 day money back
guarantee if it doesn't work for you
you're not losing anything that's Oh max
boost calm slash up hero today to get
70% off that one month supply plus free
shipping and the 60 day money back
guarantee Oh max boost calm slash
Schapiro terms and conditions do apply
Oh max go check it out right now okay so
the media's response to Kanye as I
mentioned before first of all there was
their shock and horror that Kanye would
even be in the how dare he men we get to
the actual racism so a bunch of
Democrats are just racists they're just
racists they think that the color of
Kanye's skin should dictate his
political viewpoint that is racism now
I've said in the past that when there
are people who say I am Jewish and I
believe in abortion for example I've
said that's not a Jewish principle you
know why cuz Judaism isn't an ethnicity
only it's a religion it's an actual set
of principles it's like saying that if
you're pro-abortion and you say that
you're Christian that's really difficult
to say because Christian is a set of
principles black is not a set of
principles white is not a set of
principles Asian is not a set of
principles
it's an ethnicity it's a skin color it's
a race okay none of those should dictate
anything having to do with what goes on
inside your head
obviously because if we thought that it
did that would be textbook racism but
the left likes to engage in textbook
racism it's their favorite thing so we
begin with Donna Brazile donna Brazile
you'll recall was the briefly the head
of the DNC before it was learned that
she had been allegedly leaking questions
in the debates to Hillary Clinton to
help her defeat Bernie Sanders when she
was working over at CNN here is what she
tweeted out hashtag Kanye West has set
us back a hundred and fifty five years
wish says juror truth could have met him
outside the White House and Frederick
Douglass inside the Oval Office Barack
Obama never would have become president
with this crap but let's meet Kanye on
election day by voting for Democrat
so let's do the dating here Kanye West
has set us back 155 years well it's 2018
no subtract 155 and you were talking
about 1863 when slavery was still
present so let me get this straight
and uber wealthy black guy like a
billionaire black guy goes to the White
House to meet with the president
hugs the president and gets the
president to embrace criminal justice
reform that he is pushing specifically
because he thinks too many black men are
in prison and that's the same as slavery
according to Donna Brazile that's the
same as slavery according to Donna
Brazile oh okay
sure why not okay that was not even the
worst can that was just the beginning
then there was then there was the CNN
contributors who decided to mock Kanye
as a token Negro who was illiterate
because there's nothing that says I'm
not racist quite like calling a black
man who thinks differently a token ego
who's a Negro who's illiterate nothing
quite like saying that just astonishing
here's two separate two separate
Democrats on CNN saying this one of them
is Bakari sellers and the other is Tara
Seth Meyer and it's just it's just bad
stuff kanye west is what happens when
Negroes don't read and and we have this
now and now Donald Trump is going to use
it and pervert it and he's gonna have
somebody who can stand with him and take
pictures
[Laughter]
okay that's objective news anchors on
lemon laughing as Bakari sellers says
that that Kanye West is what happens
when Negroes don't read ok well imagine
if anybody had said that about like how
many books does jay-z read or Beyonce so
I think that they are the the great
learned of Western civilization I mean I
don't know I doubt it but does that
matter they're allowed to have their own
perspective this idea that Kanye West is
illiterate because he disagrees with you
is basically racist it's essentially
racist but my car resellers can get away
with it because he's a black man so it's
okay because Bakari is black and Kanye
is black he can call Kanye West a token
Negro who is essentially illiterate and
doesn't read books as opposed to
actually engaging with his argument that
wasn't the worst
either then April Ryan shows up so April
Ryan is supposedly a reporter she's
actually mostly an activist and chews on
CNN and she brought up a guy named Ray J
now for those of you who are not
culturally fluent Ray J is most famous
for having done a sex tape with Kim
Kardashian who is currently Kanye West's
wife so Kanye West is married to Kim
Kardashian Kim Kardashian rose to
prominence off the on the back no pun
intended of the Ray J sex tape April
Ryan went for comment on the Kanye visit
to the White House to the guy who
stripped Kanye's wife on tape before she
knew Kanye all-class these members of
the media just all class here's April
Ryan Zoo in that routine text messaging
with Ray J you know who Ray J is he's he
was once close with Kim Kardashian he
said I think that it's great a great
opportunity for young black
entrepreneurs and artists to talk
one-on-one with the President of the
United States of America and he goes on
to say this but and watching the tank
from CNN he did say he's a little
concerned there is a concern right now
okay reaching out to the ex-lover of a
guy's wife for comment is just I mean is
it that is not even beyond the bounds of
journalistic ethics that's too beyond
the bounds of ethics period it's just
beyond ethics heads it's crazy stuff
that's crazy why in the world would you
think that Ray J has anything unique to
offer to the situation except that he
once slept with Kim Kardashian on tape
that's how is that even on CNN like how
to CNN call itself a news network and do
that sort of thing that's just garbage
it's just garbage I think it's even
worse than that so Don Lemon who is a
disgrace to the name of objective
journalism it's amazing like there are
people who I think tried to be objective
on CNN I said before I think Jake Tapper
very often tries to be objective and
tries to actually do his job Don Lemon
has has forsaken all relationship with
objectivity but still somehow calls
himself an objective news reporter not
an opinion journalist here is Don Lemon
in invoking Kanye West dead mother to
attack him his dead mother to attack him
don't worry this is just journalism guys
so much journalism so much reporting
happening right here this was an
embarrassment
Kanye's mother is rolling
over in her grave I spoke to one of her
friends today or text it with one of her
friends today from Chicago Dantas
friends I used to live there I know him
she said Donda would be what would be
embarrassed by this is that an OK thing
is that something that we're doing now
we're allowed to Tek people's dead
relative use their dead relatives to
attack them not their dead relatives in
the sense that like their dead relatives
did something wrong but in the sense
they a dead relative who you didn't know
and know nothing about and had a
relationship with this man that she
would be ashamed of him that she would
be ashamed of Kanye West like that's
this is sick I'm sorry this is just sick
and the media is overwrought reaction to
the fact that Kanye West shows up in the
White House is indicative of a couple of
different things one it is indicative of
the fact that when a black person says
they like President Trump the media
hates no one like a black person who
said they like President Trump no one
because they have violated the tenants
of intersectionality which suggests that
we all think like our group we all think
like our ethnic group so if you break
away from that ethnic group or you break
away from that sexual group right you're
a gay person who likes Trump or you're a
woman who likes Trump if you're any of
those things then you are a traitor but
we saw this with all the women who
supported Brett Kavanaugh they were
there were sex traders they just given
in to the patriarchy they had
internalized The Handmaid's Tale and now
we see this with Kanye West he's a black
guy who's really white on the inside
he's an Oreo right I'm these black on
the outside but white on the inside he's
in the sunken place as people are now
saying right this is it that sort of
stuff he's deeply racist but that's why
the left is so upset with Kanye is
because he breaks two of their rules one
he's a black man who supports Trump not
allowed to he's the celebrity who
supports Trump also not allowed for
people to understand how much Trump is
hated in Hollywood you have to
understand that in Hollywood if you even
express a remotely right-wing opinion
you will never work again never work
again
I've said this before I have celebrities
who listen to the show their major a
play I'm not talking a celebrity's I'm
talking a plus celebrities who listen to
this show and I've visited with some of
them I've had lunch or breakfast people
have come into this office one of quite
famous and I always tell them do not
mention that you have been here if you
wish to work in this town because the
bias in Hollywood is so extreme that it
doesn't matter your size of celebrity if
you say that
even associated with me and I didn't
vote for Trump in 2016 if you say that
you associated with me just a mainstream
conservative who's pretty reasonable
then that is enough to lose you jobs
right that actually happened out here
with Mark Duplass who just got destroyed
right mark Duplass the guy who directed
wild wild country on Netflix and he's
done a bunch of other he's on the mini
project he's done a bunch of other stuff
he came in here because he wanted to get
a pro-gun opinion from somebody for his
new movie and so he came in and I gave
him like an hour and a half and I said
him don't tell anyone you've been here
because if you do it will blow back on
you and then he foolishly went on
Twitter and said I was a nice guy and it
ended his world he was attacked so
harshly on Twitter he deleted the tweet
and then put up a tweet apologizing for
ever having tweeted that I was a nice
guy right apologizing for that that's
how it works in Hollywood so Konya he's
broken two rules he's a black man and
he's extraordinarily famous and if you
are a black extraordinarily famous
person you are not allowed to be Pro
Trump and you are not allowed to be
concerned of it anyway
you have to toe the liberal line you
wonder why to send his great shock and
dismay taylor swift came out and
embraced the democratic party because if
you do not embrace the democratic party
and you are a celebrity they will tear
you down
you know we on the right joke for a long
time about the fact that that taylor
swift did not send anything politically
because the left kept calling on her to
say something politically well
eventually she did because she finally
was pressured into it well we'll talk a
little bit more about this plus we will
get to the mailbag in just a second but
first let's talk about your imminent
doom we're all going to die we know it
okay it's going to happen sooner or
later I hope later for you but no matter
when it happens you want to make sure
that your family is taken care of and
they are not left begging in the street
your children orphaned like street
urchins instead you ought to have some
life insurance and the way that you get
good life insurance is by going to
policy genius policy genius compares
quotes from the top life insurance
companies to find the best policy for
you
it takes just two minutes to get a quote
and if you don't know the first thing
about insurance they've got all the
tools you need to get up to speed learn
the difference between term and whole
life insurance calculate how much
coverage you need and be sure you're
making the right decision in fact over
four million people have used policy
genius to shop for insurance policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy
they also compare disability insurance
home insurance auto insurance so if
you're looking for life insurance this
is the place to go and other types of
insurance as well whether you know
something or
nothing about insurance start your
search of policy genius calm they also
have lots of tools for learning about
how exactly you can get the best
insurance in just two minutes you can
compare quotes make an informed decision
for you and your loved ones policy
genius is the easy way to compare it and
buy life insurance go check it out right
now
policy genius calm okay we're going to
talk a little bit more about the Kanye
of it all can you I believe it we'll get
to that in just a second but first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire and subscribe and get the rest of
our show live you get the rest of
Michael Knowles's terrible show live and
get the rest of Andrew clavin's show
live and get all of those things plus
you get special access to another
Kingdom which I talked about earlier in
the show season 2 episodes 1 & 2 are
available to subscribers today so go
check it out
right now it's got a really cool visual
component that we haven't tried before I
think you'll like it go check it out for
$9.99 a month or for $99 a year it has
returned the greatest of all beverage
vessels it was missing was on the road I
used its cloaking device but now it is
back and it is better than ever and
filled with the tears of leftists who
don't like Kanye West and are very upset
with him this morning go check it out
over at daily where I come for $99 a
year which is cheaper than the monthly
c99 sounds like it's more than nine but
it isn't because it's for the whole year
so you should get the annual
subscription not just the monthly
subscription go check it out right now
also subscribe over a YouTube or
SoundCloud or iTunes any of these places
and leave us a review at iTunes
those five-star reviews really help us
don't leave us those three star reviews
cuz you're a jerk leave a five star
review and those are the ones that we
want so go check it out right now and
you get access to the Sunday special if
Jackel willing coming up with a bunch of
big-name guests or coming up over the
next month we're very excited to
announce those as they come out we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's talk for one moment
more about this celebrity stuff again
Kanye broke two rules black man
celebrity can't support president Trump
if you are either of these the polls are
showing that President Trump actually
has a shot at breaking out of the five
to ten percent box Republicans have been
in in the black community for a long
time and that's because as it turns out
as I talked about yesterday minorities
are not wedded to the woke social
justice warrior version of politics that
the Democratic Party wants to embrace
Kanye is showing that right now and that
is good because there is an important
signaling element to the belief that
it's okay to break out of the box that
when you expand the Overton Window which
is what Kanye is doing right now then
people have the ability to think more
freely more publicly that's quite a good
thing and I think we should be grateful
to Kanye for that even if we don't like
the celebrity politics in which we are
engaged and even if we think that all of
this is quite stupid so we'll talk about
that probably a little bit more next
week and we'll talk about it on our Fox
News election special that is coming up
our final episode on Sunday at 8:00 but
let's jump into the mailbag we haven't
had like a good solid mailbag in a while
so let's do it let's do a mailbag
crystallin says hi Ben when you take
your weekly and holiday Sabbath's and
have to unplug I'm wondering whether you
have a hard time letting go of the news
are we able to forget about it and just
focus on your family and activities or
are you distracted and chomping at the
bit to find out when what's going
outside I don't have Sabbath but during
the cabin on a Kavanagh debacle I had a
hard time even shutting down to go to
sleep have a meal or take a drive thanks
for all you do well after years of doing
it you sort of get used to the fact that
you're not going to get the news and so
you stop sort of chomping at the bit and
there there's a radical shift in sort of
the pace of life on Sabbath and on yom
tov that the holidays i even though in
the newspaper comes as somebody who's
ensconced in internet news which is
instantaneous print news is always you
know 24 hours behind basically so i
usually know everything that was in the
newspaper on saturday already by friday
afternoon but with all of that said i
find it refreshing i mean it's nice
though the worst thing is coming off of
Sabbath right when you come off of
Sabbath and you just get hit with the
tsunami of news that is kind of
difficult but I've gotten over I think
the desire to it's actually a relief I
actually get to do what I call my
serious reading my non news based
reading no philosophy or deep history
where I get sort of my back
knowledge from Vince has been what do
you think is the best major city in
America to live if weather is a factor
thanks love the show well I mean if
weather if weather is a factor then San
Diego is the best city in America I mean
San Diego's weather is just spectacular
year-round it is just great all the time
in terms of just great American cities
you know I lived in Boston for three
years aside from the weather it was
fantastic but that's a big aside from
because I went to Boston and I'd go in
late August for the start of the school
year and they suck are you because late
August is beautiful in Boston
late August in September just great and
then it's October and from October to
April it's just garbage it is just sleet
and rain and snow and then you get like
three weeks of niceness and the school
year is over so you got like six weeks
combined of things being great and the
rest of it was just bad but Boston's a
great historic city it's a lot of fun to
be there when you can actually move
around so I I did enjoy Boston
Washington DC is fun to visit it's I
like DC but only for short periods of
time because I just can't take it
anymore
like they're just too many federal
employees I can't handle it New York I
am NOT a huge fan of as I have stated on
the program that's because I grew up in
suburbia and New York you can't see the
sky so I actually start to get antsy if
I can't see the sky if all I can see is
a sliver of sky between tall buildings
and I know New Yorkers have inordinate
pride in in their city and they showed
it's it's one of the great cities of the
world it's just not a place that I think
I would love to live I'm biased toward
my hometown of Los Angeles all those
kinda increasingly shabby because of
Eric our city and the Democrats out here
I mean it's it's it's really become a
shabby town they they've done a horrible
job of upkeep and that's been happening
in leftist cities all around the United
States Seattle used to be a beautiful
city and then the mayoralty over there
has just ruined the city of Seattle the
same thing is happening in San Francisco
which is a beautiful city but if you're
just talking whether you're just talking
about the San Diego is the place to be
in fact there's a study that suggests
suicide rates are higher in San Diego
than other places in the United States
specifically because the weather is good
because people in other places in the
country when they're having a bad day
they're like yeah I know I'm depressed
it's cuz the weather sucks in San Diego
they look outside and like well I guess
I'm depressed because my life is
terrible because the weather is great
Ryan says hey Ben during one of your
young America's Foundation speeches a
guy came up and asked you back
position on abortion and said the same
logic should be cause to become vegan or
vegetarian could you please explain this
to me being a religious man I believe
God put animals on earth for our
nourishment but I'm definitely
interested to hear your take on this
well first of all abortion and killing
of animals not the same thing because
human beings and animals not the same
right as I'm a believer that human
beings have capacities and rational
capacities and in a religious sense
souls that animals do not have so I
don't feel the same way about killing of
animals for food as I do about killing
of humans for any reason so that is is
not a good equivocal equivalence in the
first place as far as the argument in
favor of animal rights the fact is that
a lot of animals are relatively sentient
I mean they're they're pretty with it
and for the same reason they wouldn't
kill your dog and eat it there's not a
terrible argument kilocalorie eat it now
do we can you do it because human beings
require animal proteins who survive I
think for survival reasons and thriving
reasons there's a good argument to be
made that you should be able to eat meat
and biblically speaking when people
quote Genesis 9:3
which is the part where it says that
anything on the earth you can basically
eat when God says that to Noah which is
actually in this week's Bible portion in
the Jewish community it's important to
recognize that this was after the
expulsion from Eden and Eden the typical
Jewish philosophy is that you couldn't
eat animals that everybody was sort of a
vegetarian and in Eden which doesn't
sound that that great honestly I mean
hamburgers are delicious but I've said
before that in a hundred years people
may look back and say how could people
eat so many animals and I think that
that may be true that said we'd have to
come up with some pretty good
substitutes for animal protein better
than the ones that we have now for
widespread vegetarianism or veganism to
take place for human rights rather for
animal rights reasons Lee says dear mr.
Shapiro recently I've gotten in
discussions about the rich paying their
fair share of taxes some of my family
who are Democrats are pretty wealthy and
they feel they're not taxed enough
compared to everyone else well then they
can sign a check go for it it's all are
you gang I don't know you get to stick
your hand in my pocket because you feel
you're not giving enough I give a fair
bit of charity and the arguments they
use in discussion are the loopholes for
the rich and that the trickle-down
effect doesn't work okay there are no
loopholes for the rich all the tax
breaks exist for everyone it's just that
you only get to exercise certain tax
breaks in certain areas there are people
who get the Earned Income Tax Credit
I do not receive
the Earned Income Tax Credit because I
make too much money most people in the
United States make too much money to
receive significant amounts of money
back for the Earned Income Tax Credit
that's a loophole for people who are not
as wealthy okay so that's not a loophole
that's just the way the tax system is
structured when people say loopholes
they act like well if I pay my lawyer a
little more then he can find a loophole
in the law that's not how it works
that's not what a loophole is okay I
don't believe in tax loopholes I believe
we should play pay everybody should pay
a fat a flat tax rate or we should have
a national sales tax but there's no such
thing as a quote unquote loophole that
only applies to rich people it's just
there are different types of income like
capital gains versus traditional income
and we can discuss whether those are
good policy or bad policy but the
language of loopholes is inaccurate how
about the trickle-down effect does it
work well the trickle-down effect is a
term that is coined by leftist
economists no one on the right has ever
suggested that there's something called
trickle-down where you give money to
rich people and rich people suddenly
make everybody else wealthy the idea is
supply-side economics meaning that
people who develop new and better
products drive the economy that the
economy is not driven by just handing
out money to people who buy things the
economy is driven by entrepreneurs who
create new and better products and that
creates its own demand so nobody knew
there was a demand for cars until cars
were mass-produced and suddenly everyone
knew there was a demand for cars
nobody knew like in 1950 there was no
demand for iPhones now there's a high
demand for iPhones because entrepreneurs
created new and better products and that
made your life better I talked about
this a little bit earlier this week the
why that wage stagnation since 1979
means that the quality of living since
1979 is stagnant is just idiotic and
ignorant we live far better than we did
in 1979 without any doubt whatsoever and
that's because supply-side economics
works ronald reagan's supply side
economic theory led to the greatest
peacetime growth in the history of the
nation economically speaking so let's
see Justin says do you think the left is
successful in driving independent voters
into the Wrights corner and if so is
this dangerous as they won't question
the right for fear of the left hash tag
party tribalism yeah I mean I think that
you should join the party with which you
agree you shouldn't join a party simply
out of opposition for another party so
if I'm an independent and I don't like
the Republicans cuz I think whatever and
I don't like the Democrats cuz they're
crazy
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
should love the Republicans you can vote
based on which one you think is the
lesser of
evils it's not an argument I love but
it's an argument you can make but I
don't think that you should simply
embrace a position because it's the
opposite of another position that you
don't like
I think reactionary politics is bad on
all sides and that's true right and left
Luke says hey Ben any music or film
celebrity you'd be interested in having
on a Sunday special well yeah I mean
they're there a bunch of them but none
of them would would come on like I I
would be very interested in having on
Tom Hanks I'd be interesting having on
tencel Washington I'd be interested in
having on Christopher Nolan whose work I
love yeah they're there a lot of film
and TV celebrities mostly writers and
directors I think that I'd be interested
in having on the actors I don't find
quite as interesting as a general rule
but that's just because I've lived in
Hollywood my whole life and most actors
are reading lines written for them
they're not the actual creators of the
material but yeah I'd love to have all
these people on but the problem is they
think that they will lose work if they
come on my show it is that simple
Veronica says what's the best way to
counter the left's gaslighting they
accuse us of what they themselves are
doing in our masters of revisionist
history even regards to their own
comments how do we fight it well the
Internet has provided a pretty good
outlet for this half of Twitter is taken
up with the left says something like oh
my god somebody said mf'er in the Oval
Office like Jim Acosta and then the
right saying dude worse things have
happened in the Oval Office the left can
only get away with this so long as there
is no venue for a countervailing attack
that venue now exists Courtney says dear
supreme overlord Schapiro I was just
recently hired for my first career job
as a seventh grade world history teacher
my question is do you think that
educators in the classroom should be
politically neutral acting more like a
moderator in discussions about political
views or is it okay for an educator to
state their point of view and
controversial topics thank you so much
for doing the show I'm really a big fan
well I I'm no I don't object to either
one I think that if the educator can do
their best to present both sides of a
topic that's great if the educator can't
do that then saying look here's my
opinion so take it with a grain of salt
and then here's a bunch of literature
that counters my opinion and you make up
your own mind that's probably the most
honest way to do it because everybody
has their biases and stating your bias
he's upfront I think is probably a wise
idea if the school allows you to do so
Charlie says happy Friday it was a five
six Christian southern conservative
educated white male who apparently
loses with privilege I appreciate
everything new and the good folks
associated with your company
this said do you ever see the mentally
ill genie of the Atlantis left going
back into the bottle or do you see
things getting worse with no one to cite
also what do you think is damaged more
beyond repair the social landscape of
our country or the damage the new Star
Wars movies did to the Star Wars
universe
thanks well the social landscape of our
country I think is more damaged than
Star Wars because I think that people
have a unique capacity to buy into
reboots so if they decided in five years
to reboot the entire Star Wars universe
we would all pretend as we should like
the force awakens and last Jedi never
happened and maybe even the prequels and
then we'd all be fine right we do this
every so often with superhero movies how
many times would they rebooted Batman at
this point a bunch so I think that we
will all get along fine with a reboot in
Star Wars land although they just
resigned Kathleen Kennedy they just
resigned Kathleen Kennedy but the you
know the the question of our social
fabric being damaged beyond repair
I'm obviously deeply worried about that
that's what my entire new book is about
Valentino says why is Batman your
favorite superhero when his only
superpower is the plot well his only
superpower is being extraordinarily rich
and being extraordinarily smart now I
ask you why is Batman my favorite
superhero because Batman is the most
shaded of all the superheroes right
Batman has a dark side Batman's kind of
an antihero um I also am I have to say
I'm a fan of Frank Miller's Batman
so Frank Miller did a comic that nobody
appreciates except me called Batman and
Robin All Stars in which Batman is
basically a sadist who enjoys his job
and I have to say that I enjoy that
version of Batman because the version of
Batman one who's always conflicted and
sad about what he's doing maybe he just
kind of likes going after bad guys like
I kind of like that's what I liked about
Batman V Superman is that Batman in that
film was great Superman was a problem
because he wasn't charming but Batman in
that film forget about Ben Affleck the
character was drawn like Frank Miller
would meaning that it was hardcore
I enjoy branding criminals and hurting
them and I don't mind killing people
like okay I'm with you that's fine right
remember Batman doesn't live in a world
where jailing people is actually an
option that's why Batman never makes
sense in the context of Gotham City
because Batman in Gotham City
all he does is jail people in Arkham and
then they immediately escape and killed
10,000 innocent people
well at that point you got to kill the
criminal right if they can't hold the
guy you have to kill him cuz otherwise
if you don't kill him
you're sending back to jail he escapes
again you come back to jellies it means
what happened to the Joker every five
minutes and that's why wouldn't Batman's
like I can't kill the Joker it's like no
you should totally kill the Joker dude
like you really should if it were a sama
bin Laden and you were putting him in
Gitmo and then every five minutes who's
escaping and committing a terror attack
at a certain point you put two in his
face hey Joel says is the Democratic
Party in a state beyond recovery due to
its embrace of socialism and raucous
behavior should be able to throw the
Dems in the waste bin of history with
the Whig party well I mean as they
currently stay current least and sure I
would prefer a democratic party that was
not insane pressing actual solutions
that maybe I disagree with so we can
have an honest debate about the issues I
think that a two-party healthy system is
worthwhile and I think that right now we
have a sick party in the Republican
Party in a dying party in the Democratic
Party at least in terms of ideology and
the problem is that there are a lot of
people who believe in that ideology okay
a couple more see Sean says hi Ben I
believe wholeheartedly in free market
capitalism I've been a follower of
Milton Friedman and Thomas old for years
I believe that type B discrimination
should be allowed in the private market
as competition naturally disinclined
business practicing unethical
discrimination type B discrimination
I've talked about on the show type a
discrimination is you're black I won't
hire you
type B discrimination is I don't have
any information about you and I'm banned
by the federal government from having
any information about your criminal
history and a person from a group that
has more criminal background just
statistically comes into my office how
do I assess that so of calls that type B
discrimination because it really isn't
your black I won't hire you it's I have
to use the statistics available to me
and the statistics happen to cut against
your group so that's what he's talking
about he says type B discrimination just
to define it as my question is where
should the line be drawn or sure the
line be drawn by the judicial system in
cases of fraud embezzlement theft or
larceny is it morally consistent to
oppose the anti-discrimination laws but
not the specific cases of malpractice
listed above well I think that it
depends on the crimes so I guess the
question is if you're talking about
insider trading I am NOT a fan of
insider trading laws I think insider
trading laws are actually of no benefit
to the to the public of the United
States in fact if you
want to make sure that there's more
transparency then you should get rid of
insider trading laws because you should
just assume that if you work for a
company you're going to have knowledge
that you're going to trade on that
knowledge and then the market is more
responsive because we just watch what
the executives of the company do at
their stock they have to have
professionals who watch what those
executives do with their stock and if
they're short selling their own stock
you know the company's going to tank
it creates faster-moving velocity in the
economy as opposed to shielding the
public from the information and then
there is sort of three steps removed
from the actual information Steve says
dear Ben I recently started a new job in
Corrections and received training on
unconscious bias which I found to be a
load of crap do you think unconscious
bias is true no I think unconscious bias
is indeed a load of crap there's very
little evidence to suggest that the
unconscious bias against particular
groups manifests in behavior in fact the
creators of the implicit assessment test
actually say this I said this at USC and
there is a guy who got up and he was
asking questions about and he pointed to
a study from 2007 suggesting the doctors
who showed unconscious bias in studies
were less likely to prescribe certain
drugs to black people and he actually
looked up the study because I want to
know the evidence what the study
actually found is that that was true but
the people who are prescribing the drugs
less often to black people were
prescribing at parity levels with white
people meaning that if you were not
unconsciously biased you were over
prescribing drugs to black people that's
at that study actually found so it
didn't actually show bias in action so
unconscious biases is one of the least
it's one of the least supported
scientific theories out there it's
really bad science and the implicit
assessment tests are not duplicate bull
meaning you can take them twice and get
different results and they are not
verifiable in the real world meaning
that they are not always connected with
behavior okay you know what let's let's
just skip the thing I like today because
we don't have time let's go to things
that I hate okay so the view I still
want to be under show that's like come
on just do it already come on this is
this is one of my aspirations in life is
to be on the view but I criticize them
frequently so I say I guess I get it I
guess I got it guys okay in any case the
view went after a Melania Trump why well
because she's Melania Trump and her last
name is Trump and she's married to Trump
so they went after her because they said
that she is willfully ignorant right
this is the same spiel they give about
Ivanka she is complicit
okay but I'm complicit and what like the
first lady is not an elected position
what is she supposed to do
first I've never understood this idea
that we're supposed to care what the
first lady thinks they really I don't
understand like no one goes to my wife
and asks her a political opinion because
she's not in that profession she's a
doctor okay but on the view on the view
they started ripping into Melania
because Melania supposedly wasn't
reflecting their their ideas or
something here's here's the view going
after Melania Trump the First Lady of
the United States telling women
everywhere your word is not enough I
think it does so much damage this is
also the same woman that in the midst of
what happens to Puerto Rico war jacket
they said I really don't care do you so
when she threw down that gauntlet I've
decided not to care about anything she
says from now on what she wears okay
well I don't think you should have cared
what she wore what she died in the first
place like why would you I didn't care
what Michelle Obama did or said except
that when she was campaigning for Barack
she's had some pretty bad stuff but I
don't really care what she has to say
now like I didn't care what Hillary
Clinton said when she was first lady I'm
happy when they say good things because
I'm happy when anybody says good things
but am I gonna get like really exercised
about the First Lady of the United
States not really she wasn't elected
nobody put her in that position hey this
is why it was so bizarre that Hillary
ran for Senate after being the wife of
the president it's so it's so weird to
me that is a pure case of non feminism
is just riding coattails obviously
obviously think of a man like John Kerry
were to marry up for money like John
Kerry and then use that money to get
elected to the Senate like John Kerry
and then get married to a richer woman
like John Kerry and then run for the
presidency like John Kerry then I might
say that he wrote a woman's coattails to
high office but again the attacks on
Melania are just silly and inappropriate
and stupid all right
well we will be back here on Monday but
but Fox News Sunday our final episode of
the Ben Shapiro election special it's
been a privilege and a pleasure being on
Fox News on Sundays our ratings are
blowing it out and we are excited to see
you there we have a great show lined up
for you so be there or be square 8:00
p.m. Eastern to view the final episode
of the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
election special it's it should be a
blast so go check it out
on Sunday and we will see you back here
on Monday for much much more I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire Ford publishing
production copyright Ford publishing